all right michelle hello michelle
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally i am originally from toledo
ohio
but moved to lutz florida when i was
very young
and tell me about your childhood you
have both your parents uh my parents
divorced when i was three
and i've lived with my mom most of my
life
how would you describe your childhood my
childhood i have been a
nudist uh pretty much my entire life
even as a kid even as a kid yes
you were living on the in the resort i
was not living in the resort but we came
here
every weekend and we lived in basically
a nudist household where we would just
basically be naked
and of course when people came to the
door we would put on clothes
but you're doing everything having
dinner naked you're dinner naked
uh watching tv naked everything naked
and this was driven more by your mom or
your dad my mom
this was with my mom how did dad feel
about it dad did not know
um i told him when i was 18.
so you guys hid this from your dad the
divorce made that easier
yes we did not tell my dad until i was
18.
and he never really accepted it he
passed
um in 2017 and he never
understood it his entire life
so it was
weird with him but uh it's still
um i still live in a naked household and
uh my mom and i own a place together and
her boyfriend lives with us
and it's still a naked household do you
have a boyfriend or a husband i have a
boyfriend
and is he part of this community as well
uh he
is getting into it and um
he is accepting it and
starting to enjoy it
tell me what most people don't
understand about it because you know in
america in the united states
it's like nudity is a big deal
people are very uptight about nudity yes
it's a very misunderstood culture
uh it's just basically
we do everything like normal people
we just don't wear clothes and it's
you mow the lawn naked you well i don't
you people
not you but right yeah other people yeah
you could blow the lawn naked
there's people there's a guy in the lawn
naked there's people playing volleyball
naked there's
a band that's out there playing
everyone's dancing naked exactly yes you
do everything you
eat dinner you you know watch tv
and everybody has this little smile on
their face and everyone's relaxed it
seems very pleasant here
it's very pleasant everyone is accepting
of everyone
there's all types of body types and
there's all different
uh you know real you know there's
any type of religion uh there's all
types of
uh races uh you know everyone is
accepting
um it's great it's just fabulous and you
know i
growing up i was never body conscious
and that's what i think people need to
to know is that being a nudist
is just so self-freeing
and it's really
just it's just a lifestyle
that is
so calm
and open and we're also
accepting of people we actually have um
i'm actually uh a member
at uh paradise lakes which is
a awesome resort that um
which is where we are right now which is
where we're at right now and
uh we it is a clothing optional resort
and they have the water volleyball seven
days a week
and they have uh
wii bowling they have karaoke and this
is all done
naked and it's great and everyone is
accepting
people live here uh they have a hotel
i mean i just love it i've been a member
here since i was nine
and i am 36 now and
i just i absolutely love it if i could
live here again
i just live here shortly briefly if i
could live here again i would
and there's also
a group that i belong to and
um i am actually on the board of
directors i am the member
excuse me i'm the membership director
it's called the united naturist and we
are a group
of young adults and also
we actually don't have a cap but we get
together
we are an inner chartered
club and we promote other nudist
resorts around the country
and we're actually started in florida
and we have
different resorts that we get discounts
for our members and
it's really really just a you know
great culture tell me i mean it seems
like everyone's in a good mood here
everyone is
always in a good mood you know in the
real world where we're all wearing
clothes and you know wearing
sweatpants and t-shirts
or whatever it's
you don't see that kind of relaxed
atmosphere
and i wonder you know humans are born
naked
we weren't born with exactly jeans and
t-shirts or whatever so
i just wonder if being naked is almost
more natural for us
it's so much more natural do people get
altercations here and get in arguments
and fights and things like that like
they do at the
grocery parking lot and all that kind of
stuff no i mean rarely if someone gets
super super drunk oh yeah well that's a
different story that's a different story
but no i mean people are just so
friendly here
um i uh took my boyfriend for the first
time over to lake como which is another
nudist resort
and we went on a tour and just on the
tour
people were saying hey welcome to como
welcome to como
just random you know people who live
there
and stuff and he was just like he felt
so invited
um just on that tour itself and it's
just
people who are nudists are so welcoming
we all are and we are so friendly i
think it's just because we're just so
free
and there's there's nothing to hide now
does this
bleed into like the relationships that
you'll have
i mean are are there is it just that
you're naked or is there also like a
sexual
aspect to this i am not in the sexual
aspect
of it there are some people who are
i guess are there different types of
nudists there are different types of
nudists there
are uh nudist naturists there
are nudists um who
are also swingers um
who are in a different that's like
a different i mean i'm not one but
there are different there are swingers
there are
um naturists there are naturalists
who are more
i would say i guess they're called tree
huggers
i mean there are certain different types
um
i i don't discriminate against any of
them
um and we try not to
none of us really do uh you know
everyone does their own thing
um you know as long as you know for me
i'm like you know what if you're a
swinger that's cool just do it in
private
that's that's fine with me you know
every each to their own
i wonder if by being naked you just kind
of
drop a lot of the things that that
humans have that make us
unhappy you know the the the facade
yeah or something i i don't know exactly
what the word is but it but it seems
like
just looking at everybody here and just
seeing you just telling the body
language everyone's just like relaxed
yeah we're all chill yeah everybody
everybody
not just some everybody we're all we're
all real chill and
i've actually brought i has to do i
bring first dates to the news resort and
they'd be like i'm scared and you know
what if i
get hard and i'm just like you know what
trust me we'll eat dinner and then we'll
go to like
the hot tub and after 10 minutes they're
fine
they're just like oh people aren't
really looking at me people aren't
you know like judging me and it's just
like it's chill
and they love it
so i've actually converted a lot of
people uh
what we call textiles to the
nudist lifestyle and do you have
children
i do not have children but there's are
there kids here too there are children
here
um at paradise lakes they're uh welcome
to 5 p.m
because of the way the um
entrance and exit is set up there's only
one entrance and exit so
they're they can only be here till five
other resorts are set up differently so
that
they have more entrance and excesses so
they can be in certain places longer
um it's basically based on
like liquor licenses and stuff like that
but uh yeah children are welcome at
paradise children are welcome at a lot
of different other resorts
and people live here like children live
here
and it's great i mean when i grew up
here there was a whole gang of us
um that actually lived here and there's
no history of
child no sexual abuse or anything like
that
no no it was great you know living
uh growing up with people who lived here
and stuff we had our own little clique
and
no no problems i mean they do background
checks and
yeah do you have friends that uh
have children no friends that know
you're a nudist and they're not and they
they frown on it or they no actually all
my friends
everyone i meet knows i'm a nudist um
and if you
can't accept me as a nudist uh honestly
you can't be my friend
so uh honestly like you're not hurting
anybody no exactly
you're just you're just having fun naked
exactly and
but in america in the united states they
people will
a lot of people are prude yes most of
my friends are
they accept it and they would love to
try it
a lot of them i've brought here or to
another resort
uh some of them are just like okay
that's cool you do you
i'll do me um but even some of my
friends let me be naked at their house
and
so if you go to somebody's house you'll
be naked and they won't be and you're
cool with that yeah and they're cool
with that they're cool with that
yeah yeah i have i have some really cool
friends and you're more comfortable
naked than with clothes on
i am yes as long as i'm not cold
southern florida especially you're kind
of yeah most of the time we have like
two weeks of winter you wouldn't want to
be doing this in minnesota no
definitely not in minnesota yeah that's
why i live in florida
sunny florida any crazy stories or
anything like that
um well we have like we have water
sports
uh i mean we have sports there's sports
like regular sports of
all kinds um uh water volleyball is a
very big one actually
volleyball itself is a very big sport
with nudists
um we have uh the tikis
uh which is um a very big group that
goes around the country
and they have tournaments all throughout
the year naked volleyball tournament
they could
volleyball tournaments all throughout
the year um
even up north uh there's some coming up
um like the banana rom cup uh the
tiki tumble uh
there's like so many like anything super
bowl
and super bowl sounds it's more of a
social it's just well no it's a it's a
volleyball
yeah i know but it's kind of an excuse
it's a competition but it's an excuse to
be social
i'm guessing both because it's it's you
get medals
and people do get and they are very
competitive so you have teams you have
they of camping they do uh
bonfires music i mean there's it's
big and no one ever gets out of line
sexually no not at all
not at all because it's it's not meant
it's not
for sexual reasons and it's it's a very
what is it is it about freedom
is it about just like um being a free
spirit and just like doing what you want
to do and not
not being restricted or bound by the
the rules of society well these are
very big volleyball players
volleyball i'm talking about this the
nudist camp of the nudist resorts uh
they just yeah i mean it's just being
free
and stuff and they just you know these
are people that just love
to be naked and they love
i mean there's this is a very big uh
there's a very big volleyball following
you wouldn't believe for
for nudists um
how many how many members are at this
resort i hear
um i don't know how many members are at
this resort um
roughly 100 500 oh god at least
at least probably i would say a thousand
at least um
i honestly i don't know recently um
but i would say probably between 500 500
and a thousand
at least and there's many of them here
there's money yes yeah
yes there's that i mean just just in
this tampa area there's
a house in the pasco county area
this is the newest capital of the united
states
in a five mile radius there are six
nudist resort communities
in a five mile radius so of right here
um and it is
saturated with nudists communities and
resorts and it's fabulous
and i don't want to move anywhere else
unless
i'm moving into one of them all right
michelle
thank you so much for sharing your story
pleasure and have fun out there this
weekend i will
all right thank you very much
you